foreign
so it turns out there's a super simple
solution to the climate crisis
do you want to know what it is
good I was hoping you would say that
all too often the climate crisis is
Illustrated with images of polar bears
of wildfires and of floods
while the headlines talk about
government negotiations and Net Zero
targets
which makes it all feel so far removed
from us
but there's something we're not being
told
and it's that 65 of all greenhouse gas
emissions are generated as a direct
result of household consumption
so that's you
and that's me
what this means is we have enormous
power to solve the climate crisis and
one of the simplest and most effective
ways in which we can do this is to do
something that humans have been doing
for thousands of years
but in Modern Life
we've largely forgotten
put simply it's to share more
and waste less
take food for example
globally one-third of all the food we
produce each year gets thrown away
which is worth over a trillion US
dollars
and the environmental impact of this is
nothing short of devastating
if it were to be a country food waste
would be the third largest source of
greenhouse gas emissions after the USA
and China
that's because a land mass larger than
China is used every single year to grow
food that's never eaten
that includes land that has been
deforested soil that has been degraded
species that have been driven to
Extinction it also includes all the
packaging and Manufacturing
refrigeration and distribution too
and when a third of that food gets
thrown away
most of it ends up in landfill
where it creates methane which is over
25 times more deadly than carbon dioxide
the environmental impact of food waste
is so devastating that project drawdown
which is a collaborative piece of work
by several hundred of the world's
leading climate change scientists
recently identified reducing food waste
as the number one most powerful lever
that Humanity has to solve the climate
crisis
coming above electric cars above solar
power and above a plant-based diet
to put all of this into a context it's a
little bit closer to home the carbon
emissions from just one kilogram of food
waste let's imagine your food waste
caddy for example is equivalent to the
carbon emissions from landfilling how
many plastic bottles do you think
one
fifty a hundred
no
000 plastic bottles
so where does all this food waste take
place
surprisingly enough it's not at a retail
store level
in a country such as the UK which is
typical of much of the western world
half of all food waste takes place in
the home
which means that we each and every one
of us we are half of this enormous
problem
on the one hand that's pretty depressing
but if you flip it on its head it can be
incredibly exciting too because it means
we don't have to wait for governments or
businesses we can be half the solution
I grew up on a farm where food waste was
pretty much a crime
and where sharing with second nature
from a glut of marrows to hand-me-down
clothes from a pony to a tractor
but in Modern Life we've largely
forgotten how to share
that's because we all live in our little
boxes stacked on top of one another
beside one another
we're no longer connected to our local
community
and so we no longer have anyone to share
with
that's why along with my co-founder we
created Oleo
Olio is an app that connects people with
their local community so they can give
away rather than throw away their spare
food
how it works is really easy
let's imagine you're going away for the
weekend or you've overcated for a party
or perhaps your toddler's favorite food
yesterday is their most hated food today
I think you've been there
how it works is you just snap a photo of
your food and add it to the app people
living nearby get an alert they can
browse the listings request what they
want and pop round to pick it up
now you might be thinking who on Earth
would want my spare food
but there is no shortage of demand the
average listing is requested in less
than 25 minutes
and it's in response to this demand that
we now also work with businesses such as
supermarkets restaurants cafes and
canteens
this is powered by 60 000 trained
volunteers who are members of our
community who are under allotted time
and day they pop out of their house and
they cross the street they go to the
store and they collect all of the unsold
food
they take it home they add it to the app
within minutes people living nearby are
requesting it and minutes later they're
popping around and picking it up
taking that food from having been
considered waste in the store
to instead on average in just two hours
being fully redistributed into multiple
homes in the local community
this now enables businesses to have zero
food waste locations
and our aim is that any business
anywhere in the world can come onto the
platform and organize for their food to
be redistributed in the local community
in minutes
so that perfectly good food is given
away not thrown away
we launched in North London in 2015 and
since then over 6 million people from
all around the world have joined us and
together they have shared 66 million
portions of food
this has had an environmental impact
equivalent to taking 200 million car
miles off the road and has also saved
over 10 billion liters of water because
food production is incredibly water
intensive but what's most exciting is we
are doing a tiny fraction of our full
potential to just imagine the impact we
can have as we get millions and millions
more people sharing
now whilst the environmental impact of
food sharing might seem quite obvious
what's less obvious but no less powerful
is the social impact of sharing
not only does it feel amazing to give
away something that you don't want to
someone who would like it
sharing also creates connection and
strengthens community
over 40 of our users tell us that they
have made friends through the app and 66
say that his improved their well-being
and every day we hear countless
heartwarming stories in particular
during covert and the cost of living
crisis which reinforces the power that
doing something so simple as sharing
your spare can have
the power of sharing can be applied to
so much more than just solving our food
waste problem though
it can also help solve our
over-consumption problem more broadly
which is best exemplified by Earth
overshoot Day
Earth overshoot Day is the day and the
year in which Humanity has used all the
resources that the Earth can replenish
in a year
back in 1971 Earth overshoot day was the
25th of December
what this means is that we used in a
year what the Earth could replenish in a
year
we were living in equilibrium with the
planet
fast forward to today
Earth overshoot day was the 28th of July
what this means is that every single
thing
that every single one of us almost 8
billion people are consuming after the
28th of July is net net depletive to the
planet
another way of looking at it is that
collectively right now we're living as
if we have 1.75 planets
which clearly we don't
it appears that we are shopping
ourselves to Extinction
and this has to stop
when most people think about playing
their part and living more sustainably
the first thing that tends to come to
mind is recycling
but given our Relentless rate of
resource consumption
we clearly cannot recycle our way out of
this mess
what we need instead is a brand new
model of consumption
one where all of our stuff goes from
being useless to useful from who would
want this to I would love that
from getting to giving from buying to
borrowing
from despair
to Hope
sharing instead of shopping needs to
become the default
that's why we've extended Beyond just
food sharing and our community can now
also give away unwanted household items
such as toiletries cleaning products
kitchen appliances books clothes and
toys and they can also lend and borrow
things instead of buying brand new as
well because let's face it we don't all
need our own air mattress or cat carrier
or disco ball or even dare I say it
popcorn maker
it gives me enormous hope to know that
we are part of a broader Global movement
of real sharing economy companies that
are springing up all over the world
connecting communities to share
everything from clothing to cars
and we're all United by this simple
belief
that the status quo has to change
and with businesses and governments
doing so criminally little to solve the
climate crisis we have set ourselves an
enormous ambition
we want one billion people to be
consuming virolio by 2030.
because contrary to popular narrative
what we do as individuals does count
after all
it was billions of small actions that
caused the climate crisis in the first
place
and so surely by the same logic
billions of small actions can help get
us out of it thank you
[Applause]